[Music]
starting with spicy black beans with
feta and avocados
[Music]
[Applause]
first in a pan heat olive oil add
chopped onion and Fry until soft
then finely slice garlic
and chili
add cumin
cinnamon and black beans then combined
cook together until deliciously soft
these small beans come dried or in tins
and there are a great cheap ingredient
to make dishes more substantial to serve
dollop the black bean mixture on crunchy
tortillas topped with Cube ripe avocado
chopped fresh coriander and crumbled
salty feta cheese
spicy black beans with feta and avocado
a Dish as filling Frugal and tastes
fantastic